[Music]
little Liz bring the boat have you been
in how did you get here
it began when our parents told us to
take a rickety trolley to briny Beach I
have some very bad news for you children
your home was destroyed and your orphans
now we went to live with tunnel he threw
it Josephine's at the leeches which
inspires with us my squalor and crumbly
Espace he kidnapped a quagmire triplets
murderer Jacques sneakin in the village
of el Divo Jesus you can't prove that
Baudelaires I need your help
this is the most important mission VFD
history let's not hesitate you
disappoint us I laugh a little their
fortune is small potatoes no I'm pretty
sure it's money just submarines ready
I will envy Ft once and for all
please remember Thursday to the last
safe place so tell Dana ma sail
volunteer of course we welcome this
hotel is packed with familiar faces our
enemies are getting bolder should all be
in danger I will get my revenge on
everyone what do you think they're up to
baby
things aren't always what they see in
Baudelaires our parents were training us
for VFD we didn't even know it we can't
live on the run forever
don't you have any burning questions
any unsolved mysteries
don't you want to know what happens next
what happens next
violet Klaus and sunny Baudelaire
my name is lemony snicket is what
[Music]